[Music]
hello and welcome to the
values of the west debate now the west
one saw itself as the driver of global
progress
we were confident that enlightenment
values would guarantee success
uncover knowledge and create progressive
social change
but now many of us are beset with doubt
critical of our past we have little
faith in the future and
in the power of our core beliefs to
bring about a better world
so is this self-criticism a welcome and
less arrogant
outlook a consequence perhaps of western
imperial guilt and
relative economic decline or should we
overcome our doubts and reignite faith
in our values and
in their power to improve lives or
should we instead just escape our
history
to fashion a new set of ideals that
we're proud to endorse
and which drives success all very
difficult questions but luckily we've
got a great panel
to help us disentangle them so kai indi
andrews
is an academic activist and author who
appears frequently on
tv radio podcast online to discuss his
research
in black studies miriam francois is a
broadcaster and journalist who's a
research associate at the school of
oriental and african studies
and her website is we need to talk about
whiteness.com
and physician philosopher and novelist
raymond tallis
is emeritus professor of geriatric
medicine at the university of manchester
and has been described as one of the
world's greatest living polymaths
so lucky us now what i'm going to do is
to ask each other three of them
to do their three-minute pitch on the
question of
why have we come to have doubts about
the values that made the west successful
and i'm going to start with kai indy
good afternoon so
i mean i think the first thing to start
with is to say that the myths that we've
been given about our society is
essentially a lie
uh we've been told that the
enlightenment these great values
um built the west that was built on
industrial progress and it's this great
march forward into history
and that has always been untrue and
what's what's happened there
is you have children from the former
colonies here i like myself
have platforms have jobs in academia and
are able to be a bit more critical and
to say well actually
the kind of progress narrative of the
industrial revolution political
revolution
and scientific revolution is partly true
but actually the west was also built on
slavery colonialism
and genocide and actually when we look
at what the real values of the west are
we will therefore find that racism
patriarchy
violence these are all deeply embedded
in what the western project
has always been and now you have people
with a platform to say that that's
that's what
that's what's caused this existential
crisis i mean i work in universities
up until relatively recently the
university was the place the province
the safe space
uh for rich white men in 1960 only five
percent of the population went to
universities was elite
white men so we shouldn't be surprised
that we've had this very narrow
uh progress narrative and now that's
opened up and you have some more
critical voices we ask time to look at
and say well actually how is the world
really
shaped you couldn't have had the
industrial revolution without slavery
and colonialism
and genocide you couldn't have had the
foundation of western science and
modernity without
uh it's the kind of colonial violence
that's taken claim to millions upon
millions of lives
there is no political or an economic
system that has been more violent and
there's
more death to the world than western
liberalism uh
just from from its very inception and
also
we think about these things as being
historical things have passed and we've
progressed into this newer age
but one statistic alone would debunk
that whole thing a child dies every 10
seconds because they don't have access
to food they know and almost all of
those children are black and brown
children in the underdeveloped world
and kovit19 has made us have a kind of
existential look at this there's so many
people dying in the west
nine million people die from poverty
every single
year and all those nine million people
who live our black and brown lives
almost all of them have black and brown
lives
in the developing world and what kovid
has shown us is actually
he just brought in the experience that
this is how most people live where
actually
this is a matter of life and death so
when we think about the values of the
west we have to be thinking
about a proper reappraisal racism
patriarchy
violence those are really the values of
the west that sustain it as much today
as sustained in the past
and we need to have an honest
conversation about what that means
okay thank you miriam
so why have we come to have doubts about
the values that made the west successful
um i think there's a lot for me
personally to unpick in that question
the first
one is whenever we use the term we i
would question
who it is that gets to speak as we um
because certainly the idea that these
doubts are new
for everyone who is identified as a
citizen
of this very fluid notion of the west
um is is an erroneous one i think not
everyone's experiences
of the mythology of the greatness of
western values
um is suddenly being uh placed into
question now i would
um obviously be referring if we want to
talk about
more recent history people like uh
gretel gokan who the 80
one year nhs nurse um who was deported
back to jamaica from the um
the a woman who came from the windrush
generation uh brit
britain british served britain in the
nhs
and then obviously her identification
with
the west being placed into question um
i'm not sure that's a new
uh experience for uh people like gretel
i would also
argue that it's probably uh the
perception or the mythology of western
greatness
as is normalized within centers of
empire is probably not shared
by the relatives of the 17 million
indians who died of hunger
between 1891 and 1900s so i mean
this idea that there is even a consensus
over
what constitutes western values and
their quote-unquote successes is
to be placed into question quite
seriously i would argue
a second point is about the this notion
of the west
um it's a term that becomes popularized
i would argue during the cold war era
when we have this idea of the world
being divided between two blocks
but it's also worth thinking quite
profoundly about what it is
that this term means it's obviously a
social construct we're not talking about
a territorially defined entity it's
usually meant to include
america and the uk does it include
europe if it includes europe do we
include hungary which is currently led
by a fascist
do we include the fascists within
america
and the uk do we include israel which is
placed in the
center of the middle east um and so in
that sense
i think the notion of the west itself is
is a
what i call a power play which is an
assertion
of a unified uh construct
when in fact it's not very unified and
it
essentially serves to delineate who's
excluded from
that camp and my final point would be
about the west's
success can we just be very careful
about what we mean by success do we mean
success in terms of um you know
capitalism
the fact that a large amount of wealth
has been accrued by
a small minority of people primarily on
the backs of people
in the so-called developing world um but
it also off the back of many
people who are descendants of those who
were exploited and who live
today in the uk in varying levels of
poverty and so
i'm not sure who gets to define that
success but currently i think it does
require
perhaps a bit more of a nuanced
assessment than the current mythology
would have us believe
okay thank you and ray talis i have to
say i share
most of the concerns that have been
expressed by miriam and cayender
certainly it's obvious that the material
success and political power of the west
was to an important degree based on
empire building
and contrary to the story i was told at
school the colonisers were not engaged
in spreading truth enlightenment
civilization and prosperity
across an ignorant and unenlightened
world we are now coming to see
too little too late perhaps the extent
to which colonialism was built on racism
the presumption of white supremacy and
involved genocide enslavement and
exploitation
and there is a powerful argument that
the continuing global inequities
are to some extent the continuation of
the colonial era by other means
however to what extent was what orwell
described as
excuse me again as the dirty work of
empire the product of western values
distinctly or uniquely western values
the barbarism of the colonial era was
not unique slavery has been and remains
a human universal
the slave trade in classical greece and
rome and the arabic slave trade
are a reminder of this servitude and
destitution
justified by the high-minded often those
called by their gods to enslave others
has been a feature of all societies and
other societies not particularly driven
by western values
have embedded servitude in for example
caste systems
and it continues worldwide today in the
appalling discrepancy between those who
have the power of consumption
and those who toil to produce so does it
follow that we should reject
the values that made the west successful
some values we should most certainly
reject
indeed they can hardly be called values
the assumption of a god-given right to
invade and possess
lands belonging to other people
propelled by a myth of spreading truth
and progress across the world
but there are other questions how much
of the barbarism empire was value driven
or was it a matter of something more
universal greed
arrogance the misuse of power and
secondly are there other professed
values that it would be a
disaster to jettison among the
enlightenment
professed commitment to universal rights
to justice
to democracy and to an approach to
understanding the world that is based in
science would we wish to get us on that
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas
you